[Música]
mi nombre es ángela gómez y esto es ella
soy cada 8 de marzo se reivindican las
luchas feministas y los logros del
activismo en la búsqueda de un mundo
igualitario este año para conmemorar el
día internacional de la mujer ellas hoy
se une a sus programas homónimos desde
las cadenas de france24 en árabe francés
e inglés con una edición especial
dedicada a las mujeres defensoras del
feminismo
[Música]
en 2020 los derechos de las mujeres
fueron el tercer sector más atacado de
la defensa de los derechos humanos
las activistas se enfrentan a
detenciones campañas de difamación
agresiones físicas y acoso
[Música]
lianne angela quien encabezó la campaña
para permitir que las mujeres conduzcan
en arabia saudita fue liberada
recientemente después de casi tres años
en prisión
la activista climática india dicha rave
fue arrestada y puesta bajo custodia sin
abogado en febrero
vanessa rosales en venezuela ha
enfrentado un continuo hostigamiento
judicial por su trabajo de apoyo a los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos de las
mujeres en bielorrusia la activista de
derechos humanos maría rap cofa fue
detenida y acusada como parte de una
ofensiva contra las protestas en curso
algunas incluso pagan el precio máximo
44 mujeres activistas fueron asesinadas
en 2020 predominantemente en américa
latina con la mayor cantidad de muertes
registradas en colombia honduras y
méxico
nuestro primer reportaje desde libia
varias destacadas activistas y políticas
fueron asesinadas o víctimas de
desaparición forzosa en los últimos años
entre ellas se encuentran se salva y sea
asesinada a tiros en su casa en 2014
seham sergewa una parlamentaria
secuestrada en 2019 y la abogada anna
albar ha sido asesinada el pasado
noviembre nadie ha comparecido nunca
ante la justicia por esos crímenes pero
eso no detiene la lucha nuestro equipo
conoció a dos mujeres que pese a los
riesgos están determinadas a lograr un
cambio
de borja mike and trends la guerra ha
afectado a mi país de muchas maneras me
di cuenta de que este tipo de cultura de
la guerra ha afectado a las mujeres
jóvenes a las quienes estoy clase en la
universidad veo a los padres esperando a
sus hijas en frente de la universidad
porque no hay seguridad enfrentan
acciones bears típicas de westhouse
securities y la miss pensar regreso a
una libia destruida por la guerra en
2015 esta profesora de farmacología
quedó tan impresionada que se convirtió
en activista política en 2019 era muy
peligroso y todo el tiempo se oían
bombas explosivos cohetes en su barrio
en las afueras de trípoli estaba en la
primera línea de uno de los conflictos
más recientes
shauis siempre son las mujeres las que
sufren durante y después de la guerra
son intrínsecamente pacifistas
lamy será una de las 17 mujeres de los
75 participantes en las negociaciones
interrumpidas de la unión europea en
ginebra que trataban de reunir a las
facciones beligerantes de libia tras una
década de inestabilidad en gran pista
durante los diálogos de paz hubo un
fuerte compromiso por parte de todas las
mujeres no sólo estábamos ahí para
hablar sobre temas relacionados con las
mujeres como creen algunos actores no
hablamos sobre todos y cada uno de los
elementos que habíamos expuesto en la
agenda roadmap la misa ha enfrentado
amenazas e intimidaciones por estar al
frente en un país donde otras mujeres
activistas han pagado con su vida de
haberse dejado en gómez hay un riesgo
algunas mujeres han sido secuestradas
entonces eso ha llevado a un retroceso
en la participación de las mujeres y en
el compromiso con la política de zeeland
engagement
pero tenemos la energía para continuar
necesitamos estar ahí por nuestras
creencias y por las nuevas generaciones
en este país las mujeres están
determinadas a construir un mejor futuro
la artista a diaganá trabaja por
restaurar el centro
de trípoli las pipas de agua se van a
quedar como están pero la electricidad
irá por este lado
para javier el camino es ayudar a las
mujeres a tener más espacio en el ámbito
público las mujeres en realidad tienen
mucho poder en libia socialmente por lo
menos si tan solo se despertarán y
educarán bien a sus hijos antes que nada
la libertad debe tomarse y no se puede
entregar las libertades de las mujeres
todavía son un trabajo en curso en un
momento clave para el futuro de libia
desde nuestro estudio en parís están más
alumnas ar presentadora de ellos hoy en
árabe en el young de fifty one presente
en inglés y virgin y hertz en la versión
francesa actuales vamos al análisis
primero con más alumnas are my salud
incluso cuando las activistas no se
ponen la bandera de la lucha feminista
sino que trabajan en otros activismos
parece que sólo por el hecho de ser
mujeres se convierten en un objetivo de
los violentos como es este fenómeno en
el mundo árabe
ángela desafortunadamente angela a las
mujeres en los países árabes no sólo
pagan por su activismo también pagan por
el hecho de ser mujeres a causa de la
tradición de las costumbres y de las
leyes conservadoras que oprimen a miles
y millones de niñas y mujeres allí por
ejemplo una mujer que se casa puede ser
víctima de la legislación en materia de
divorcio de custodia de los niños y en
materia de derechos sin embargo si la
mujer decide no casarse la llaman
solterona y será una víctima de bullying
social
sawers fallida tussam a anne schuchat a
pagar al stand amor wide otro ejemplo es
el de una mujer que disfruta su libertad
corporal de zorrilla es vista como una
prostituta pero si decide tener
relaciones sexuales legales podría ser
víctima de violación marital aunque la
nota taras del artista serie cesárea les
de rodillas además de eso las madres
amas de casa permanecen bajo el control
de sus esposos porque no ganan dinero y
cuando deciden encontrar un trabajo
están bajo el control del mercado
laboral y con seguridad serán víctimas
de las brechas salariales
por eso desafortunadamente en el 2021
las mujeres son asesinadas simplemente
porque son mujeres y cuando deciden
volverse activistas
la sociedad las hace pagar el doble
pagan el precio por ser mujeres y
feministas al mismo tiempo
una dieta sana shaman marazzi y virginie
las defensoras de los derechos de las
mujeres también son defensoras de los
derechos humanos finalmente lo que
buscan es igualdad no pasa lo mismo con
los hombres activistas que no
necesariamente tienen perspectiva de
género usted qué opina
hola ángela 11 y de japón de uaga de
adisto haga que a lo largo de la
historia sorprende ver que en efecto la
mayor parte de las que lucharon por los
derechos de las mujeres también lucharon
por los derechos humanos y la democracia
pero lo contrario no ha sido así el
cordón de esa declaración universal de
duch último de hecho es sorprendente
notar que tras la revolución francesa de
1789 la declaración universal de los
derechos del hombre excluía a las
mujeres peor aún es que old and the
course que militaba para que esa
declaración incluyera a las ciudadanas
fue guillotinada furyk wat y fan vice
que el monto por la purísima de esclavas
de ayer de junio feminismo con él es
interesante notar que ella también
militó en contra de la esclavitud
al igual que ella otras pioneras del
feminismo lucharon por los derechos
cívicos y políticos permítanme mencionar
dos ejemplos la alemana clara zetkin fue
una marxista pacifista y es la mujer
detrás del 8 de marzo
en eeuu angela davis ha luchado y sigue
luchando contra el racismo y el
patriarcado agapov heridos
creo que no pague tema por tom zé kuri
fam podríamos seguir mencionando
ejemplos las que luchan por los derechos
de las mujeres luchan por la igualdad y
por una sociedad más justa con senegal
mochi que dice basket surf and food fast
and sexismo anei del coi 19 cambio las
herramientas de trabajo para la mayoría
de activistas del mundo nos vuelco aún
más social las redes sociales esta
crisis genera un aumento del activismo
definitivamente pero las redes sociales
son una bendición y una maldición la
mayor bendición es que por supuesto es
una plataforma para el movimiento michu
para la campaña times up y aquí en
francia para el balance triunfo y es
algo que continúa por ejemplo con las
recientes denuncias de incesto y con una
campaña realizada por estudiantes de una
de las universidades más prestigiosas
del país y antes por realizaron una
serie de acusaciones de violación
aunque las mujeres todavía tienen poca
representación en los medios las redes
sociales incitan a que haya un terreno
de juego más amplio permiten que las
voces de mujeres se encuentran en una
serie de contextos y países más diversos
con o sin poderes tradicionales sean
escuchadas como dicen algunos permiten
que haya una especie de liberación
colectiva eso significa que todos somos
responsables de acabar con el sexismo y
la violencia sexual de afirmar michu
pero la otra cara es el acoso
cibernético y como todos lo sabemos muy
bien cuando una mujer hasta la voz puede
atraer una cantidad inmensa de acoso
cibernético y enfrentan también amenazas
físicas estas plataformas de redes
sociales necesitan hacer mucho más por
acabar con este comportamiento abusivo y
lamentable
gracias a ned y para nuestro segundo
reportaje de este especial volvemos a
américa latina la región del mundo más
peligrosa para quienes defienden los
derechos humanos y para las mujeres en
méxico cada día al menos dos mujeres son
asesinadas simplemente por ser mujeres
el país azteca tiene una de las mayores
tasas de feminicidios en el mundo sólo
en 2020 se registraron cerca de 1.000
muertes pero hay mujeres como frida
guerrera quienes han dedicado su vida a
combatir la violencia de género
ella como periodista y como activista
informe de mario carbonero
afuera de palacio nacional el 14 de
febrero de 2020 un grupo de mujeres
realizó una encendida protesta adentro
una mujer periodista y activista también
alzaba la voz allí afuera están gritando
mujeres porque porque llevamos más de
250 feminicidios en lo que va del 2020
más de 300 homicidios si hablamos en
general porque no existe así como existe
una fiscalía antisecuestro especializada
para ese tema porque no existe una
fiscalía especializada para el tema del
feminicidio
ese día verónica villalvazo mejor
conocida como frida guerrera cobró más
notoriedad en su labor de difusión de
casos de feminicidios a raíz de eso el
hostigamiento hacia ella aumentó aunque
en realidad lo ha padecido desde 2016
de amenazas de que voy a ser el próximo
feminicidio de que mi cabeza ni siquiera
voy a ver darme cuenta en qué momento me
la van a aportar siempre que hay un
feminicidio sólida busca estar ahí un
ejemplo es el caso de victoria pamela
salas martínez una joven cruelmente
asesinada por su pareja una mujer
como pocas y yo creo que nadie nadie en
la vida va a ser como ella ella se ha
encargado de
de visibilizar todos esos casos que han
estado en el olvido porque así nos dejan
enterrados psicóloga de formación cuida
sabe cómo acercarse a las víctimas
primero cuando yo me paro en frente de
una familia tengo que hablar entrevistar
al dolor
y darle contención que lloren que se
enojen y después viene la empatía y
cuando ellos ya lloraron y ya se
enojaron entonces yo siempre hago esa
pregunta ahora presenta me la y dime
cómo era porque yo no la voy a conocer
qué sentiste cuando te embarazas te y
entonces ella sonriendo a pesar de las
amenazas
frida está decidida a continuar su labor
vice alumna el esquema de amenaza y
represión a las mujeres también es una
constante en el mundo árabe cómo
interpretar la reciente liberación de
los llena hattula la activista que
estuvo en prisión tres años por defender
el derecho a conducir
foto baja ante la cruz sin alas de la
mina aces en bagdad ex leila wa leila
por supuesto angela el hecho de que la
salud haya salido de la cárcel después
de mil una noche de detención arbitraria
tortura y juicios erróneos es algo
positivo pero el principal problema es
que él y jane no está totalmente libre
todavía porque tiene una orden de la
corte que le prohíbe viajar durante
cinco años según la declaración de los
miembros de su familia odian a mojácar
jaque mate a la tasa de matrícula ya
edad y ya la capital y calzadilla al mus
local y aun aún está en juicio en arabia
saudita entonces no es del todo libre
además desafortunadamente en arabia
saudita el destino de todos los
activistas por los derechos humanos y de
las mujeres detenidos en la cárcel está
ligado a una presión política extranjera
sobre las autoridades saudíes y no está
sujeto a un compromiso local oa una
voluntad por cambio real en el reino
pero no sabemos en la negatividad hay
esperanzas de que cubra un cambio en
muchos ámbitos en las sociedades árabes
especialmente en el ámbito legal han ido
hemos estado hablando aquí de los
riesgos que se asocian con el activismo
en américa latina y en el medio oriente
pero incluso en el mundo de habla
inglesa desafiar el status quo también
conlleva una serie de riesgos
es como lo sabe cualquiera que defienda
los derechos de las mujeres el acto
mismo atrae de manera inevitable algún
tipo de respuesta negativa por supuesto
el tipo de respuesta cambia dependiendo
del lugar sin embargo en el mundo
angloparlante la vida de un activista
implica cierto grado de riesgo por
ejemplo en el caso de quienes apoyan los
derechos reproductivos en eeuu o de
personas como alexandria ocasio cortes y
nancy pelosi que fueron un objeto junto
con otras mujeres durante el asalto al
capitolio del 6 de enero también ocurre
con las mujeres que están detrás de la
marcha de mujeres y del movimiento black
life matters la diferencia por supuesto
es que no están las prisiones
adicionales como las que existen en
sociedades altamente tradicionales donde
sólo pensar que una mujer salga a las
calles a protestar es una ofensa para su
familia en términos de leyes en eeuu no
sólo está el riesgo para la resolución
roe versus wave que le otorga a las
mujeres el derecho a abortar a causa de
una inclinación conservadora de la corte
suprema sino también cuatro años de
administración trump que significó un
retroceso y un estancamiento en muchos
asuntos que afectan a las mujeres
y virgen y recientemente hemos visto que
voces por la igualdad que llegan a
posiciones de poder pues generan cambios
lo estaba diciendo antes con casos como
el de la casa blanca con el kamala
harris la primera mujer vicepresidente
en la historia del país podríamos decir
que los derechos de las mujeres han
vuelto a ser populares que cobran fuerza
en la agenda de la diplomacia
internacional
en eeuu la lucha por los derechos de las
mujeres implica un cambio de paradigma y
eso repercute en la diplomacia
estadounidense a ponce que drenaban la
administración by the woman in this way
y también resulta interesante ver que
estados unidos regresa a ser parte de
múltiples organizaciones internacionales
a los que apoyan programas de
planificación familiar y de acceso a las
interrupciones voluntarias del embarazo
organizaciones a las que la
administración trump le había retirado
el financiamiento serbias la liberación
del huyen al hat club por parte de las
autoridades de arabia saudita también
era una prioridad en la agenda de la
administración baiden y puede
interpretarse como un gesto de buena
voluntad por parte de riyadh frente a
washington incluso aunque no haya tenido
los efectos esperados por mohamed bin
salman si no haga mediquen turín avon y
juristas newsone en todo caso washington
ha enviado varias señales indicando que
los derechos de las mujeres será uno de
los puntos fuertes de su diplomacia fue
la fas y se sitúa del lado de frank
canadá o noruega que defienden una
diplomacia feminista pero atención hasta
el momento esta diplomacia feminista se
encuentra más al nivel del discurso que
de las acciones y de actuar gracias
virgin y también a todas mis compañeras
de las cadenas de france 24 por una
mirada a la situación de los defensores
del feminismo en el mundo y gracias a
ellas hay que arriesgan todos los días
su vida por un mundo igualitario siga
con nosotros en france 24
[Música]